what is the best game of golf you've
ever played I shot 72. once I was the
course was a par 71 and I was under par
on the front and my brain couldn't even
comprehend that that was the case and so
I thought that I was already won over I
lipped out a putt and then only later
realized that if that had gone I would
have been even
um but 72 that's my best have you ever
finally have you ever dealt with any
like anxiety or depression or issues
like that can you see me because kind of
a happy guy guy who has it together but
has there been ruts in your life where
you just you couldn't get it going
um I've been very lucky in that regard
um I mean look everybody from time to
time
has difficult times that's not something
that I've particularly struggled with no
I and and and so I my my I I'm not a
good person to speak to it
um
I
I guess I'm just lucky what do you do to
stay kind of like your mind off for real
you golf a lot I mean I try I mean to
play a lot but that for me is oh it's I
and the reason why is because I I am a
I I am in some ways a micro manager
right like in terms of my business and
um you know I I'm always looking at
every angle and my brain will sort of
like spin like that
um when I play golf I'm thinking of
really truly for those four-ish hours
I'm thinking of one thing which is
trying to get this ball in the hole your
mind doesn't wander and it really
doesn't and I and I also to the
frustration of of people I now my
manager I tell him I'm I'm I'm I'm
checking out like I mean I tell him
where I'm going right as opposed to like
trying to hide it or whatever because I
really try unless there's something
urgently happening to not look at my
phone like I just I put it away don't
look at it and you think that helps
significantly a hundred it helps me
first I think it would help everyone
shut your phone off every once in a
while and just go do something and
forget about yeah you know that's I mean
for a lot of people it's hiking right or
something like that that takes less time
generally than than Golf and I I know
that it that it takes a lot of time but
I'm I am by Nature you know I played
Sports growing up I'm competitive and so
that that kind of drives me yeah to do
is like no I want to play better I want
to do better I want to hit a better shot
and and you just every shot there's a
there's a potential for greatness and
also horror and horror and shittiness
yes self-loathing and all that but at
least it's just about this game and at
the end that that is I will say I will
be incredibly competitive and really in
it and five minutes after we're you're
over it oh no I'm totally over it like
yeah I don't go home healthy healthy
mind
foreign